have you ever seen these ads online
there's a guy always seems to be a guy
talking to the camera about how
successful he is the production value is
low but there's always some impressive
swag on display like a Lambo chillin in
the garage or an eight bedroom mansion
with an infinity pool if you stick with
the video you'll probably hear an
inspiring rags-to-riches story with a
hint at some surefire secret to his
success now I'm a licensed financial
professional who knows there's no magic
pill to becoming wealthy but even I
found myself wondering are these guys
for real is this just some slick
marketing for boilerplate financial
advice or is this the old song and dance
of a conman the con in con man is short
for confidence in 18-49 the New York
Herald ran a story about a well-dressed
gentleman by the name of William
Thompson he would approach a perfect
stranger and ask if they had confidence
in him to trust their watch to him for
the day the novelty of the request
combined with Williams outward
appearance trustworthiness convinced
dozens to play along that was the last
most of them ever saw their watch or mr.
Thompson we may think of a conman as
being the same thing as a thief or a
liar but in her book the confidence game
Maria konnikova explains the true con
doesn't force us to do anything he
doesn't steal we give in short their
master manipulators and our culture is
obsessed with them we make movies
podcasts and documentaries about their
schemes like fire festivals Billy
McFarlane Elizabeth Holmes of Thera
knows and of course Bernie Madoff
konnikova explains that transition is
the Khans greatest ally because
transition breeds uncertainty I guess
Littlefinger was right
chaos really is a ladder and in our era
of rapid technological innovation and
shifting online social norms the con
man's hunting ground is more fertile
than ever and we are ripe for the taking
thanks to intensely detailed consumer
monitoring check out our video about how
companies stock you online it's become
easier than ever to pinpoint an audience
interested in a certain topic for
instance someone who might be curious
about investing because they watch a
youtube show about financial literacy
topics like money and real estate are
especially promising because they're not
widely understood and that lack of
knowledge believe it or not actually
makes people less cautious this is
because of something called the
dunning-kruger effect social
psychologist David Dunning and Justin
Kruger conducted multiple studies where
people were tested on subjects like
logic and grammar been asked to rank
themselves on how well they thought they
the participants who scored the lowest
tended to rank themselves the highest as
students with high competence tended to
underestimate their performance
basically the less knowledge you have
the more you'll overestimate your
abilities so if you don't know anything
about investing you're much more likely
to believe someone who tells you you can
beat the markets that's not to say there
aren't any honest-to-goodness golden
opportunities out there but sadly they
are vastly outnumbered so how can you
tell the difference
well most cons tend to follow a familiar
script first the con identifies their
potential victim known as the mark your
browser history and tracking cookies on
your computer and phone make this very
very easy the next step is to befriend
them and earn their trust that's where
the wealthy selfie comes in this conveys
success but also approachability he's
not a slick marketer just an average pro
like me next they drop a hint about the
reason behind their success usually some
secret easy to learn process that
doesn't require any intense training or
hard work and they're willing to share
it with you then they provide social
proof of their authenticity like
hyperbolic testimonials our numbers of
followers on Twitter and Instagram money
finally changes hands this might take
the form of a special introductory offer
or easy minimum commitment which the
mark is usually all too eager to take
part in think
big profits are just on the horizon
finally we reach the sad conclusion the
money's gone and the hoped for profits
never materialized if executed by a
master the mark won't even complain
blaming his own bad luck or lack of
faith rather than the guy who took him
for a ride in this day and age it's not
likely that you hand over your money and
get absolutely nothing unless you're
trying to help out a Nigerian prince but
often the actual product or program you
get is subpar hard to execute or just
boilerplate pump you up self-help advice
designed to boost your confidence all
while maintaining the impression that
the pot of gold is just around the
corner to keep you moving through their
highly curated sales funnel into more
and more expensive offerings now is that
a con it depends on who you ask but
consider this how much time money and
energy are going into the sales pitch as
compared to the product or service
itself just because the video looks
cheap doesn't mean they didn't spend
gobs of money plastering it everywhere
and does bind the initial product seemed
to open you up to increasingly expensive
programs those are all major red flags
that you're being sold an empty promise
if you're realizing you've fallen for
something like this in the past
don't feel bad the fact that we're all a
little gullible is actually a positive
thing as konnikova explains the simple
truth is that most people aren't out to
get you trust not adeptness at spotting
deception is the more evolutionarily
beneficial path and while modern
technology might be making new
opportunities for con artists it's also
never been easier for you to uncover
them so do your research and ask
yourself if they have all this money why
do they need yours and that's our two
cents thanks to our patrons for keeping
two cents financially healthy click the
link in the description if you would
like to support us on patreon
if you've ever fallen prey to one of
these schemes
what are some other red flags to look
out for share them with us in the
comments
[Music]